Hey, what's going on? It's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Just checking in on you.
How are you?
We've got the lovely Nia with
me. Hello. What's going on?
Oh it's Christmas needy.
I know. City sidewalks.
Pretty ladies.
Everybody walking around spending
money on people that annoy them.
You take your dick out and a charger game.
Rub it up and fucking down.
No, I feel so bad for that kid.
Why? Why do you feel bad? Cause I
have a dick and I know how hard it is.
You know how hard it is?
No, sorry. No Pun intended.
He was in public. I know, but he
just looked like that kind of guide.
He did not have talked to.
Look if he's a fucking like seriously.
I mean if he's fucking like, you can't
control rubbing his dick in public.
It was entrapment.
They had like 12 fucking scantily clad
women and the whole thing that SRAP meant
, let me ask you a question. He was
not a game. There's cheerleaders there.
And how were they dressed? Oh, so it's
their fault. How are they dressed?
The way she really isn't
always says that this,
why can't you guys ever be
flattered when a man flash issue,
that's a fucking woman ever just whipped
her who are out because I look so good,
no fucking tee shirt and it would just
fucking make my day as long as she stayed
away from me. I mean, he was,
she was doing its own thing.
You know what's hilarious? Fucking
pervert the way doing it in public.
You know what? I loved the way he had
his arms crossed. He was like, well,
I can't see what I'm doing.
That means no one else can get an idea.
Get a fucking the new technique. I never
tried the overhand before. Thank God.
The cross control the crossover overhead.
That's like an Olympic level jerking
off through his pants. You know? Look,
everybody you know you, that's how
you get caught. You know, you fucking,
you can't cheat you. He got greedy is
what happened. You know what I mean?
He thought he could. He, you know,
he thought he could do like fucking
20,000 people staring right at him.
Yeah. But you know,
okay, and, and, and look,
when I'm talking about those
cheerleaders, why are they out there? Nia?
Why are they really out there to
stir the crowd up to cheer more? No,
they're not spreadsheets.
They dress him like fucking
like just shy of who is,
that's what they're out there for.
They got their cleavage,
they get their butt cheeks hanging out.
Everything's barely covered.
Everything's all shiny, glittery,
glittery and shit. You know,
hey, what the fuck was he supposed to do?
You know, not touch his dick in public.
Hey, that's what he was supposed to be
there. But for the grace of God, go,
I really trying to say that you would
be in a position where you would just be
jerking off through your
pants in public like that.
[inaudible] I've never stood next to 12
women all dressed in the same sparkly
outfit touching their toes in front of me.
Wearing some very user friendly slacks,
accidents, slacks, action
slacks. They were, and you know,
you're saying you wouldn't
be able to control yourself?
I would say half to touch.
If I have to take my my life savings,
if I have to take my life savings says
no way. I'm betting on black slacks.
I'm not, there's no way I'm
going to put it all on one thing.
I don't know what I would do if I had a
couple drinks in me. You know? Who knows?
Might do the, oh no. Who knows? Who knows?
Every guy's done that don't want
your golfing public. Oh, absolutely.
Now they have at some point they did
something. They were in their car.
They rubbed one out. They did
something. They weren't a porch. Well,
guys are always talking on a plane,
on a plane.
They went to the bathroom and just
rubbed, went out. The amount of men,
I'm just saying the amount of fucking
men have done it. The year is like, Hey,
yeah. You got to understand when, wait
a minute, wait a minute, wait a minute.
What's that?
I you say that you've gone into a plane,
like a bathroom on a plane and jerked off.
I know I have not done that.
What are you going to do? I
don't know. Scold me. Yes.
Goal to Shaman. I know, listen guys,
I've, the way they talk to other guys,
Shit that they've done or
whatever, you know, hey,
we've all done stuff we're not proud of.
You know,
didn't Jesus say he was not fucking
rubbed what out to a fucking cheerleader?
You fucking cast cast the front.
You know what I hate is if that,
if that's the worst that that kid does.
Okay.
Which is basically all he did was
completely humiliate himself. All right?
And his life is fucking over it. I mean,
isn't that enough? I feel bad for them.
I do.
Unless he's like really a pervert and
he's running around grabbing women and
he's ruining people's lives,
then yeah, then you know,
put the kid down like a rabid dog without
a doubt. But if it's worst fucking,
you know, I love about it is
they say men can't multitask.
There was a man clearly
operating as a security person
while rubbing one out that is
multitasking one hand free.
So I don't really feel like he was at
his full capacity as a security guard
while a lot of securities just presence,
just people seeing you,
seeing you with your dick taking your
hand. He had his gun in his hand.
I feel bad for them. Don't feel bad.
Just hear those sleigh bells ringing.
Link, tink, tink tingling too. He's
like, you know a homeless child.
Come on and rub one out.
Fucking cheerleader or to keep
the rubbing. Keep the rubber wild.
Everyone watches. Oh my
God. That poor bastard.
A tweet that this person has Sunday, man.
I Dunno. Can you stay focused here? Yes.
I'm trying to tell you my, can I tell you
my story today? I went out. I went into,
well, you don't have to be here. What
do we watch it on? TV. Nia. It's the,
it's The Washington capitols first.
The Philadelphia. Oh wait, no, I don't.
You said chargers.
Don't know Philadelphia fucking fly.
Why is this is rivalry Wednesday?
That's Wayne Simmons. I can't get up on,
have my feet up and I'm pregnant
and I'm the size of a house.
That's why I'm here. No, you're not.
You look like an Igloo more than a house
that's, do you look like asshole? Oh,
just the shootout. What do you think of?
Oh, that was a nice movie. He had
them tuning, skipped off his stick.
I don't like to fly. I don't like the
gold numbers on that. While you fly.
He's got such a great uniform that
kind of fucks it up a little bit.
You know somebody's got to buy it.
You know that guy just paints his room.
Fucking orange and white little
biggest fan ever. You know, you know,
if you dedicate your whole bedroom, you
know painting it, your team colored.
There's no way you can judge that kid on
the charges because you definitely wear
slacks and you rub one out in
public. Oh sheet. Just fuck you.
That was a fuck you. I don't respect you
as a goaltender. Didn't even do a move.
He just stared at him and was like,
this is going in the net bitch.
And that's exactly what the fuck
capital of this Jesus Christ. Yeah.
Led on in you right there
Fred. Fuck you. That's one.
Nothing in over time. Oh,
sorry. Two, two. All right,
here comes another flag comes down.
He dipsy Oh, little head go out.
Too many fucking Moe's. See
what he did? Claude Euro.
I liked,
I love the head fake in hockey.
I mean it works in basketball and
fucking if you're a wide receiver,
but as you're gliding and it just never
seems to work. Uh, he stayed home.
He stayed home. All right. No one wants
to listen to this shit. So anyway,
so I go to target today. You literally
just had your arm over your eyes.
Like it was the most torturous thing ever
to listen to them exhausted. You know,
I'm fucking tired. Thought said. Yeah.
I have friends way faster than you
and they're doing much more stuff.
I don't know what you're
complaining about.
I have so few friends that
have like morbidly obese. Okay.
And they're more active than you are.
I think you're being a little dramatic.
I they just dating life.
Mm.
I Dunno what just dating means.
Do they have another human being in
Jesus yells at Nice Go. Holy Shit.
Taking all their for the mis,
sucking all of their energy.
Ah Do they have,
they're increasing their blood flow and
their water retention and there exists
no, but they probably have a woman in
their life. Fucking Yammer and Adam,
that was a goal. I didn't think
I put the fucking number of,
I don't want to be a part of this podcast.
You don't?
No I don't cause I don't like your
attitude right now. Oh okay. I'm sorry.
How about this,
you know Nia,
what you're doing right now is one of the
most special things that has ever been
done on the planet.
Granted most of the people on the planet,
we'll do it at some point cause more.
Most people are women, you know,
and gas don't like wearing, it's sorry.
Um, all right, so I go to
target today. Well Jesus Christ,
Wade Simmons.
When you told me that earlier,
I just couldn't even imagine you
going into target on your own accord.
It just didn't seem like something that
was buying you a Christmas gift from
target. Yeah. From target. And I
couldn't walk and find what I wanted.
Why are you buying me? Oh, you know what?
Let me stop cause I'm about to sound.
Really? Yeah. You're going to
sound like what you are. Well,
I'm an asshole to twos. The final score.
What? I'm fucking old. I can't see what,
what's the uh,
the overtime score we have to get,
we have one in our eyes
examined this year.
I mean 2017 we both have to
go to the optometrist. Listen,
I think we have enough
activities together.
I already went to the optometrist
activity. It's together. Yeah,
it's not an activity I'd already got.
I got fucking four and I fly.
I got glasses so I can see the radio
channels like glass. I Gladstone,
I got the, I got the half moon things
where like I'm regular. I'm a freak.
I'm regular. I'm a freak. Bye Bye
bifocal. Yeah. I don't know what they are.
Yeah, they fucking great. I've
never seen you in these glasses.
It's cause you won't fly with me.
Your baby fly with me.
I'll take you over the ocean.
I did fly with you and we'll see some
people sitting on some surfboards as they
wait for a fucking wave way.
You fly with me,
I'll fly you over the Santa Monica Pier.
I did the whole snapchat story of it.
Yeah,
but she won't go unless I'm with
an instructor. Of course. Well,
that right then all that does is
motivate me knees. You're a comedian.
You're a pilot. You're a comedian.
That's like saying, I'm a comedian.
I don't have a license to
drive a car. No, it isn't.
What do you mean it's the same thing?
I'm not a professional driver.
I don't drive at the Indy 500 I
don't fly for American Airlines.
You get me in a Robinson
22 where the old 44 they,
I'll take you for a fucking ride legally.
Okay?
I don't know if I have enough hours
for 44 but the 22 with the two sita
[inaudible]. You can try this fucking
woman thing that you guys all do.
Did fucking thing that yanking on the
fucking range that you guys all do.
Anytime you see a guy doing something
new, you got to have that. Hmm. Well,
he thinks he fair, but he's, you'll
always shitting on our fucking hobbies.
That's what you guys do. I would love
for you to get a hobby. Excuse me.
You know what? I'm going to get
you. I'm going to get you a fight.
Listen to me when I speak.
I am the man in this relationship.
I'm going to get you a week
would whittle and shit.
I'm not shitting on your hobbies.
I'm just saying like I would feel more
secure with there is a person there who
is a professional flying with us.
Fair enough. That's so bad. It isn't.
It's fair enough. But there's a this
also part of it is that it motivates me,
motivates me. That's all. Okay, well
all right. See you then. Okay. Wow.
What does that, what do you want me
to do for me? You always say that.
What do you want from me? Hey,
what do you want for, you know,
I'm going to get you a
little Woodward only kid.
I'm gonna get you a fucking hobby.
You know what you know, you know be,
is dealing with you.
You know what? Oh snap.
When we return Nia with
more fucking snappy answers,
just tell your targets. Die,
Huh? No, I'm going to find you a
hobby. What about, what about, uh,
what's that thing that happened to
Bobby and ghost, you know? Oh God.
[inaudible]
I eat when Patrick Swayze sat on Whoopi.
Oh, uh, God made up pot plants.
Well, I'll get it. I'll get it. You're
confused. Patrick Swayze. No, no.
Don't tell him to tell me. Don't tell me
I'm going to get it. It's one of those,
it's one sick.
Fuck it.
It's one of those boots was one
of those stupid fucking songs.
It's one of those songs
woman in red your time.
Ian Read talking about what she is waking
parts with me while singing the sound
track to another Patrick Swayze movie.
You've got your two Patrick Swayze movie.
How many fucking movies are there?
Pretty good. I'm in the ballpark.
Patrick Swayze and made a lot of movies.
Um, you're talking about when the nun?
No, his comb. No, he wasn't.
And there's a body by the train tracks
and then stand by me. Was He in San Miami?
Yeah, he played more than me and guys with
key for Sullivan. Hey, you little shits.
Yeah. Don't fucking talk about the dead
body or I'll cut your daddy or off your
fucking freak. Hey, I'm fat
now. I'm married to his model.
Oh yeah.
This is you describing everybody
in Donald's Leonardo Dicaprio,
but it's a a river Phoenix. That one's
too sad. So I'm not going to do that one.
And then the other guy, hey, I'm going
to fucking talking about Jerry O'connell.
Then there's the other dude, right?
Who does the thrill dance still right?
Baby baby baby.
Ulu Du du, Du, Du, Du, Du du Du.
It's fucking 2016 I'm still doing
when this stupid fucking day.
I feel like you're talking
about Corey Feldman.
He was not in stand by me that
he was, was he? I usually was.
He was the dude with the fucked up here.
Who wanted to fight with the glasses.
Oh yeah. Yeah. I liked
him. Hmm. Today would go.
Originally you were talking about ghosts
and then you started singing the song
from dirty dancing.
Don't tell me cause I'm going to get it.
I'll get it by the end of the podcast.
Um,
you know,
one of my goals in 2017 I'm going to get
a fake id fake id for all this fucking
times. You know, you, I'm on the road. I
want to use the gym and they will come.
You need an ID and they want to
take a fucking copy of my life.
Do you know how to fake id is
illegal, right? I'm going with,
my name's going to be
frank. Falucia. Yeah,
I like alliteration. Bill Burr, Frank
Volusia, right. Teddy. Pendegrass.
All right, well, so I go and do, um,
I go into target to buy you a gift
that evidently you're up above.
I was going to get you a flat
off right next to the bicycles
targets so fucked up. Like, what do you
guys want to be? I don't like target.
They're like that person who just
morphs themselves into what you,
they think you want them to be so they
can be friends with you. It's just like,
pick a fucking angle.
It's like you walk in,
you're looking at TVs in there
next to cereal. Like what the fuck?
Like, this is like a fucking yard
sale, but everything's new. Um,
all right, so I go into target and I'm
looking for your fucking shit and every,
you know it's funny about target as
everybody looks like they work there.
So you got to ask like nine fucking
people. Hey do you work here?
And they get all offended but you look
like you do. Don't find the clothes here.
You asshole if they're wearing a red
shirt, they work at target. Yeah,
but there's different levels.
It's like the military.
There's different kinds of red shirts
does the people with the Pete Carroll
dockers and then the red shirt
tucked in there like management.
Then there's the grumpy,
filthy people who got to like fucking
unload the trucks all day and they never
let them go home.
They're not going to answer this shit.
And then there's sort of dumpy
women walking around like, I dunno,
I dunno what they're thinking.
Like they took a pot cookie and every
once in a while you meet that one that's
on the ball. Who's not going to be there
long skull. Oh, I thought that was new.
Sorry.
That's a highlight.
That was a nice fucking wrap around goal.
Oh, you got to love the wrap around.
Oh, he saved it. He didn't saved that
fucking thing. Did he? That's a goal.
That's a goal.
I would love to review the fuck
employee sleuths so like as I'm leaving,
I bought you a high end gift.
They're at target, right?
I bought you a floral apron with a
frozen burrito in the pocket and um,
I got to keep it in the freezer until
right before twas the night before
Christmas and all through the house.
Not a creature was stirring except for
this bald freckled fuck taking a frozen
burrito. I'm sticking it in the stock.
And by the way, underrated stockings,
stockings. I don't know about you guys.
Like, I don't know. Some people are like,
they start with the stockings.
Other people,
we always end on the stocking and the
stockings always liked the bump. Bump,
a bomb. Damn. Like you're
already got your cool gift.
Then you go over to the stocking and
it's like a, it's like a, you know,
a gift certificate to a book club and
you've got to sit there acting like,
oh yeah, thank you. I get to read.
Awesome. What else is in
here? Oh, new socks. I mean
[inaudible] you shouldn't have literally,
and I would rather wear one stock and
walking down the street in a pair of gold
toed socks just because
of what they represent.
There's a lot of blood and shame on
all those gold toed socks. You know?
Do you have any hookers?
Have laid on motel rooms in the last
thing that they saw was somebody bloody
gold toed sock walking towards them.
So bad,
so bad during the holiday season.
Silver Bells.
If you leaving your family going to
get oh hooker while the goose cools.
Double Life.
Serial killer.
Cops show up one day and you confess to
40 other killings and your wife says,
who the fuck are you?
What did I do with the last three decades?
And you stare at her with
no feeling behind your eyes.
I really got you. Go on this one,
man. Nini. Yeah, egging me on here.
I like your dark holiday here on,
cause I hate that song.
I hate silver bells. It
just goes on for, it's like,
it's just song on a fucking loop.
There's no way. This is one song. Oh,
did fucking fish record this fucking
thing? It's like 20 minutes long that um,
silver bells and I hate Jingle Bell Rock.
It's just such an attempt of like white
people trying to be here. You know,
we're going to, jazz is one, a
jingle bell, Jingle Bell Rock. Hey,
jingle bells.
It's that thing where you kind of just
shaking your head and your ass at the
same time. You know, as you're snapping
your fingers with your fucking loafers,
that's when somebody,
you know,
if you're at a party and there's a
piano and somebody knows how to play,
they're going to sing that at
the holidays, you know? Oh yeah.
And then there's going to be the
undersexed fucking 20 year old,
20 years married chick with the red
wine teeth always start dancing.
And it's like, all right, I am, I going
to get her out of here, get a coke,
send her home. I just don't
know why they stay together. Um,
so I'm leaving target.
I'm leaving target and a
sky looks fucking confused.
He was getting interviewed here. Huh. Um,
so I'm leaving target
and as I'm walking out,
all of a sudden I just hear
this guy go on, get off me.
And I look over and there's two target
ladies there at the Pete Carroll level of
the target thing and a in a,
in a target guy.
Two women and a guy are just fucking
grabbing this dude and they're dragging
them into like this windowless office
and the guys going, this isn't illegal.
And they just drag and
amended. Everybody's just
watching like what the fuck?
And then like the door starts to close
and then it all fucking closes again.
And then,
and then,
and then they finally got him to
calm down and they closed the door.
And this older manager just
close the door and he did that.
You know it's smile you do when you
walk by a stranger because you hope that
they don't have an ax. You know that
little purse lip, what you Kinda do?
You lift your eyebrows up. He kind of did
that like well that's the end of that.
And it's like that's an
American citizen in there, sir.
What the fuck just happened?
But nobody said anything cause its target.
You just don't expect it.
So I said to the lady next to me,
I go, did he steal something? And
she goes, no, I don't think so.
And then somebody else goes,
I think he's autistic.
And he was acting a little weird.
They dragged them into yeah,
there's bombing the back room.
Yeah. I don't think that that's,
it doesn't make sense.
Does it make sense?
But I feel like why would they take
it upon themselves to drag him away?
Why wouldn't they call the police?
I know it looked like that Scientology
show that you're watching that the stuff
that they do to people except
it was at target. You know,
I wonder if one of those people
are going to do a two t v show,
exposing target and what?
What really goes on there?
They probably wanted him to work all
three shifts on Christmas and he said no,
they just dragged him in there. They
don't fuck around at target. I guess not.
Are you fucking kidding me? Did that guy
just score from the other side of that?
I'm just watching the highlights.
It's pathetic. And that was it.
And that was the end of a,
and then I just sort of walked out and I
have to admit any rolls of paper towel.
Yes. Merry Christmas, Nia.
I'm expecting a lot of big
tears next year. Big Tears.
Big Tears. Yeah, that's me.
I'm somebody who was, I should probably
read some advertising here. I'm like,
Oh this is fun. What a great
night. We got the fire going. Oh,
tell them how much I like Eggnog.
A lot of people don't like Eggnog.
I like you love Eggnog.
I love it now too.
Well what it is is always shy
about it. Cause I was like, yeah,
I don't know if it's my thing,
but it's delicious. Yeah,
but people pour you a giant fucking glass
of it. It's, it's like in a, it's a, uh,
like a, what do they not an aphrodisiac.
What do they say? What's that shit?
You're drinking Italy. FTA.
FTA. Yeah. That's what it is.
But was shortages Steve as a
digestif you have a big meal.
You sip on a little egg. Nog
No, he's like melted ice cream
and I like it.
Wait, hold up. The podcast where
I type in my fucking pot. Yes.
It tastes like milk in it.
Melted ice cream. And I like it.
I know. I'm sorry. Guests and that.
I'm sorry because I spelled stocking that
look right to me now when I look back
and I'll be the dumbest
person ever. S t o l, K, I n,
g of stocking stuffers.
Underrated.
Let's see, I wrote some ideas. Silver
Bells, kid jerking off Christmas break.
Stoeckle Stouffer's underrated. Oh. Oh.
This is the one I wanted
to talk about when I was,
I went into best buy afterwards.
Oh,
I was hitting all the corporations
and I'm standing in line,
this pathetic line of fucking people
just waiting till the last minute to shop
or all fucking hate in life.
And I'm still, you know,
and you're going through like the Disney
world line where you got to fucking go
all the way back and forth,
back and forth.
So I'm standing on final last rung and
this guy walks up to stand in line behind
18 people. You know what is
t shirts said do epic shit.
First of all, what kind of a
fucking adult? Where's that
stupid fucking tee shirt?
Why would you wear it going to
stand in line at best buy, right? I,
that's a new fucking thing with people.
Try to motivate people with their
workout videos and shits, like kill them.
You know, like they're doing it
for you. Like what am I supposed,
when I see that guy with
that t shirt like wow,
that guy's doing epic shit in
standing in line at best buy. No,
he's taking a break.
He just,
he was doing that point break shit
earlier out in Santa Monica League.
You've got helicoptered out.
Just some sort of fucking a
burning man out in the ocean.
Whatever they do when they know
big waves coming, you know,
everybody else runs for cover. They
go, we got to go right out at it. Man.
It's another Patrick Swayze movie.
Yes it is. I saw the remake of it.
I enjoyed it, you know? Oh
yeah. Wasn't about surfing.
It's not about anything.
It's like fast and furious.
It's just about fucking fast
and furious is about the cars.
A point break is about, you know, the
stunt man and everybody do. You know,
in the flying squirrel suits in riding
waves and shit. That's all it's about,
you know? Yeah. I've
never seen that movie.
I possibly hot women with mysterious
attitudes who can't walk a straight line
without crossing one foot in front of
the other. It always in some rainy alley
possibly. How women with
mysterious attitude. Yeah.
They always fuck under
the fire escapes and Shit.
It's the same for ges alley,
whatever that is.
It's in like in every fits in
every fucking movie is alley. Ah.
Hell.
Did Sam have my loud no.
When a fucked you next to
this fucking dumpster. Oh, uh,
so rad when you bend me over. No. Um,
yeah.
They fucking the same alley where that
dude from brothers guts got his throat
cut in a way.
That fucking,
that movie where the guy who was always
screaming. Yeah. He goes every, no,
not everyone.
He goes off.
Remember that to Sean Penn?
No,
the guy who plays a commissioner
Gordon Gary Oldman. Okay.
He was in, it was based on a
jacket by the professional. No, no,
that's not that one I fucked up. It's the
one that was, it was based on that book.
The westies, I dunno, uh,
who's Ed Harris was fucking great in it.
And uh,
this was before that dude did fucking
boogie nights. He's on, he's on,
he's on a adult swim. He's in like in
every fucking movie teak played chest,
Roswell bronzy rarely John C. Reilly,
when he gets his throat slit and just
Christ. So long, long fucking way to go.
That's the same fucking alley where all
those women get fucked in all those,
those movies, you know.
Okay. All right. What was,
what is this song when
they make the make the pot
unchained melody.
Whoa,
whoa. Oh they played that
song. Whether I'm making a pot.
No wonder I never fucking could
get through that movie Darlene.
I just felt your head going down on
my shoulder while the movie's on.
Just I hate when women do that.
I always hated when I was on a date
and you deliberately took them to some
fucking schmaltzy shit cause you knew
they wanted to see it and then it comes
that stupid fucking moment in the movie.
Whatever. What's the Siren Song? Go?
It's 16 rally.
Just sing the song while I tell you what.
All right.
And then you fill,
there's stupid head starts going
under your shoulder and you know,
you're kind of excited cause
she's becoming intimate.
But there's another party that
just wants to fucking do a tie.
Domi did the all Samuelson when they
were standing in front of the net.
All right,
that's it.
So slowly we're baking a fun kid pot.
Can you don't tip it over.
I knew it was one of those things,
wasn't will Ferrell's father
and that band and what van?
The righteous brothers is that
the righteous brothers? Yes.
Of the righteous brothers
white. Yes. Oh, Jesus Christ.
Okay. I didn't know that. All
right. The white, the white, just
the righteous brothers are white. I didn't
realize that. All right. I need to read.
I need to read some.
Uh,
let's read some advertising while I
sing while I sing Christmas carols.
All right. Oh, you know,
zip and re and crew and turn.
Are you hiring?
Did you know where to fucking
pose your most favorite job?
Post your joy.
Is it,
are you hiring? Are you, that's amazing.
Do you know where to post your job
to find the best candidates? You,
it's funny your neighbors probably
think I'm yelling at you back to right.
God dammit virus my dinner.
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates, man.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you know,
in the future you gonna have to have
like do your fucking ad and like those
virtual reality glasses that people like,
whoa, wow, fucking hate that commercial.
There's old people acting like they're
blown away. You find a fucking war.
Act like posting your job in one place
isn't enough to find quality candidates.
If you want it to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top
job sites and now you can with old zip
[inaudible] dot com you can post your job
to 100 plus job sites including social
media networks like Facebook and Twitter,
all with a single click.
Oh, isn't that genius?
Everybody's on that shit.
Can we get a little more
fucking DPS zip recruiter?
Find candidates in any city
or industry nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll in to Ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office quickly screen candidates,
rate them and hire the right person fast.
Find out today why zip
has been used by over
1 million businesses.
And right now my listeners can post their
jobs on ZipRecruiter for free by going
to ziprecruiter.com/burr
that's ziprecruiter.com/
[inaudible] one more time.
That's it.
[inaudible] dot com slash
[inaudible] all right.
Distilled genes.
DSTL d.
All right. Uh, okay.
The problem with jeans is that the really
good parents because two and 300 to
get the fuck outta here,
but it's $300 for jeans.
What are you ric flair easily and the
bargain brands just fall apart or look
terrible. That's dad jeans. Distilled.
Pronounced distilled has revolutionized
the fashion industry by creating
timeless luxury grade denim.
So you get genes that would cost you
hundreds of dollars starting at 65 bucks.
How do they do it? By
refusing to work with it. Oh,
I know how they do what they scream at.
The kids in the sweatshop make them
faster by refusing to work with department
stores and retail middlemen.
There's no markup, no bullshit.
Just great jeans at an unbelievable price.
Just go to distilled
jeans.distilled.com d s t l d,
um,
spelled Dstl d.com.
Find the perfect pair with a
perfect fit. That's Delta, Sierra,
tango, Lima, Delta, little
pilots, shit there near. You'll
fly with me now, won't you?
They'll ship them to you for
free and guarantee the fit or a,
we'll send you a new pair till
they are. Perfect. All right.
See why all the a list celebrities have
been spotted in magazines like vogue,
Gq wearing distilled jeans,
even c list celebrities like me.
Look at that little self deprecation.
I've got a pair of the raw denim and
that the fit is a mate I haven't gotten.
I did get them and you said they look
good and look great on you. Yeah,
no bull said. Okay, look
amazing. All right, well,
65 bucks people you can
look like a bald red head.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com slash
bar right now and get $10 off your first
pair. That's Dstl d.com/
[inaudible] for $10 off right now.
Five letters. Everybody d
as in Dick, s as in shaft,
t like taint l like,
oh Jesus. What's that?
Lumber. What's the thing in your
vagina that begins with an Elf? Dbs.
Lavia there you go. Deal.
I never took a health
the falls. I know how to, um, I didn't
want to say that. I didn't want to say,
listen, I know what to do with it. Okay.
How did relics Helix,
I swear to God,
I cannot believe you haven't learned
how to pronounce this word yet. Shut up.
You're unique. You're like, oh, I like
how they just butter you up right here.
Helix. Hey Mia. Yeah. I don't
know if I ever told you this.
You're unique. You don't. You are.
You don't walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone sounds
like a drill sergeant. Good.
I teach you to walk like everyone else.
Talk like everyone shoot shit
or sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress
one size fits all well,
because there's an average height of
human beings. They're mass produced.
It's a cost effective thick.
All right?
Because it truly customized mattress
will cost you five to 10,000 bucks right
now. Go to helix, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions
and they'll run a three d.
It does read it. It was just funny.
The questions they're gonna ask you.
You know you actually have a unique body.
You don't have the ball,
can you balls hang up and over your leg.
Okay.
This bed mattress is going to
have to be a little wider there.
Run a three D biomechanical model of your
body through the proprietary algorithm
they develop with the help of the world's
leading era Gomix and biomechanics.
Say this is the fucking Illuminati
mapping your whole body is these is where
entity beg for you, Huh? Yeah, they
are. What is Arab era genomics?
What does that mean?
Ergonomics.
Isn't that like how you have
a chair that's Eric denomic
Lee, correct. Like it's,
it's good for your back.
Like it supports all your back and like
the proper way all your vertebrae and
stuff.
Isn't that what it means?
What is biomechanics
mean? Oh, I have no idea.
I mean mechanics are mechanics.
Bio,
it was like biology. So the
mechanics of the body, whoo.
That's probably what it means.
I'm like,
you sound like the fifth family member
on family feud when all the good answers
are gone and you just say
some dumb shit and like, hey,
you're right. Show me mechanics.
Set works in Bios. Actually,
the biomechanics, they both sounded
right to me, but I'm a morning.
He customers report at 30%
improvement in overall sleep quality.
How do you know you were asleep? And for
couples, they customize each matches.
See the sign of the matches though?
You're gonna talk about fucking your Magis
arrived into or for a couple of lady,
you bang on this fucking thing.
I'm coming 30% faster.
Your mattress arrives at your door and
about speaking of Eggnog and a bottle a
week ain't come on and
shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from
Gq magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep. All
right? Go to healing. How do you get it?
Let's see. Okay, this
is what you want. Okay?
You have a hundred nights to try
it out and if you don't love it,
they'll pick it up for free.
It's always say they sharpen
those breaking bad fucking
suits with those giant,
like you know when you're
going to catch an alligator,
except it's like a mattress thing,
right? Uh, and it's 100% refund,
no questions asked. Go to, he looks
sleek.com/burn and get $50 off your order.
That's [inaudible] dot com
slash [inaudible] he likes
sleep.com/per our last one
everybody. And then we're going to
be rocking around the Christmas tree.
You how fucking fat? Yes. Ice.
I loaded that bitch up. Alright.
Seatgeek not, you know, I went to
target near and I fucking threw it out.
Seeking buying tickets online for
sports and concerts has been a confusing
process for a long time.
It's always been hard to find the best
deal for that game or show you want to go
to. And none of those older
tickets sites want to change that.
But SeatGeek is different.
They've come along and created an amazing
APP and website that makes it easier
than ever for fans to
buy and sell tickets.
Everything about Siki Kit's designed to
make life easier for sports and music
fans.
[inaudible] does all the price comparisons
for you by searching multiple tickets
sites and ensuring that you
get the best possible deal.
Seek does all the work and
you save time and money.
Best of all my listeners get a $20
rebate off their first SeatGeek purchase.
Uh, to get your $20 rebate rebate on
tickets, download the [inaudible] APP,
go to the settings tab and
click add a promo code.
Enter Promo Code Bar Seatgeek will send
you a $20 after you've made your first
ticket purchase. Download the Sikh App
and enter Promo Code Bird today. So Nia,
yes, this is one of my favorite times
of year because I get to, you know,
hang at home for once,
you know,
sit by the fire and I got
all the sports packages, uh,
asked me if I got the NHL
Center ice package. I, yes, I do
ask me if I got the NBA hardcore,
whatever the fuck they call it of Cory.
I got that too.
Okay.
And asked me if I got NFL
Sunday ticket. Yes, I do.
I got all three so I can watch my
patriots, myself, sticks and my Bruins.
And what I've noticed with the
Celtics and the Bruins. Okay.
If the Celtics Luiz Isaiah Thomas,
it's fucking over.
They lose like they lost like fucking
three in a row and he comes back and all
of a sudden when that Memphis
game was fucking incredible.
But my DVI shut off with like five seconds
of going over time. I think we want,
um,
and then the Bruins,
if Chiron goes down where that spend the
thing the whole time though. But um, um,
you know what? I've been
bitching about Michael O'connell.
When you rebuild a team,
it takes at least two to three seasons.
So we'll see which direction he's going
in. I don't know. I don't fucking know.
But it's been tough to watch in
this year cause I love him and uh,
and I loved a lot of the guys they got
rid of and it's hard watching them on
other teams doing fucking great,
you know,
I know there's a salary
cap and all that shit.
I'm going to quit fucking
pitching. Um, so anyways,
I guess that's the podcast here
near you're gonna fall asleep.
I don't know. Oh, Jesus. Well, you know,
I'm glad I knocked this thing out before
you fell asleep. Um, everybody had them.
I got no energy. It's all right. Everybody
have a merry Christmas. Merry Christmas.
Happy Hanukkah. Happy Kwanzaa.
Happy holidays. Jewish people.
I help you have the best fucking
Chinese food. That sounds great though.
Not spend it all that fucking cash.
You just have Chinese food.
Go to a fucking movie. Uh, Greg, does that
sound? That sounds great. I liked that.
I think we ought to add that celebration
on the 26th right? We'll do that.
[inaudible] Christmas, everybody.
That's it. Happy New Year. I'll
talk to you on Monday anyways,
but I hope you guys all have a happy,
safe one and all that stuff.
And I thank you for everybody
who's been listening all year. Uh,
it is a privilege to do this.
All right, go fuck yourselves.
Get conscious and I'll talk
to you on Monday. Yeah.
[inaudible]
[inaudible] you can,
you can sit around and wait for the call.
You're
waiting for someone. Yeah. You will
sit around and wonder what to mom,
Dad,
uh,
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] Ah, Fuck Huh.
Uh
Mmm.
Happy holidays.
It's the Monday morning podcast.
I do like that little second grader
fucking recital. It was horrible.
I thought I was going to get through it
in one take. I should have been asking.
I shouldn't,
that's like the kind of guitar playing.
You hear it a benefit and whatever the
benefit is like whatever the disease it's
for.
Like if that guitar playing,
like I would have the disease that you
guys were raising money for and then in
the end they wheeled me out
and they'd be like, Hey,
here's a guy who has the disease that
we're trying to stop and now he's going to
play the guitar for you.
That's how I just played the guitar.
But I don't give a fuck. You
know, I can't help it, you know,
I can't help it if I'm fucking not even
gonna say multitalented it's not the
word. What's the reverse
of multi one dimensional.
I can't help it if I'm a one trick pony.
Anyways,
this is the Monday morning
podcasts for the, uh, uh,
the week of Christmas,
which is why I had my little recital.
Um, you know what's hilarious is last
year, um, besides my guitar playing,
um, it was last year I took
off, I didn't do a podcast on
the week of Christmas or the week of new
years and everyone thought it was cause
I, you know, I was taking
a vacation or whatever.
But the reality is is because I was
traveling and holiday travel sucks.
So as many of you know, this year, I
was like, you know what? Fuck this.
Fuck everybody.
I'm not going home for the holidays
because I'm not dealing with that planes,
trains and automobiles shit.
And I gotta tell you, man,
the smartest goddamn thing I ever did.
I don't what that says about me,
but I'm not spending it with my family
and I am absolutely fucking elated.
You know,
I'm not saying I don't like my family,
I'm just saying I don't need to go see
them when everyone else is going to go
see their family because,
uh, because it sucks.
I had a buddy of mine to,
you know,
trying to fly back east with
all this snow and all this shit.
He's down in Orange County calling me up.
That same situation I was in last year.
Do you believe?
Did really please go to two blue,
blue, blue, blue, blue. And I was like,
thank God,
thank God I made the right choice.
Fucking excited. I got a
Christmas tree. I got stockings,
I got a Ukulele. I mean, what more do
you need? What more do you fucking neat.
I don't know. Some inner peace maybe, but
I don't want to get greedy. Um, I'm, I'm,
I'm two inches away from
getting a dog. People, I know,
I've said it for about
two years on this podcast,
even though I've only been doing them for
a little over a year, I'm freaking out.
I'm terrified to get a dog because
I'm like, you know, what, if, uh,
what if I want to take off for a
couple of days? I mean, I don't,
I've never had to take care of
anything in my life, you know, and uh,
never been at a movie going,
Oh my God,
what if it's taking a shit
in my living room? You know?
I don't want to be thinking that,
especially at this time of year when
there's all these great movies are out,
you know, speaking of which, um,
somebody sent me a great email and said,
we'll get back to the dog thing.
I want to get a dog.
And if I get a dog and getting a fucking
bulldog and I'm going to a breeder,
I know a lot of people, oh my God,
you should rescue a dog. You know,
I don't have time for you. Do you
understand me? That's your cause.
You go down there and you, you, you
get all those, you get all those dogs,
you'd go down and you get them that I've
already learned how to fetch and they
just completely over everything.
Nothing's exciting anymore.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
why don't I just pick up a fucking
divorce waitress with three kids that hate
her, you know? And, and
bring that into my life.
And I'll just surround myself with people
who are just fucking over everything.
You know? Sometimes I, Hey, I just
really say stupid shit. I don't,
I don't feel any of that. You know
what? I went down to the shelter,
I wanted to rescue all the dogs and
I don't fucking know. I don't know.
I'm talking about,
I'm just trying to kill time people as
I'm trying to find that thing about the
movie reviews. Yeah. Somebody sent
me an email and they said, hey bill,
I haven't heard movie
your views in awhile.
Now some of my longtime
listeners of the podcast,
remember we used to have people write in
because I went and I saw a shitty movie
one time and I was pissed at,
you know,
I lost my 10 bucks or whatever
the fuck that charging now. Um,
so people started, you know,
thrown in that 2 cents. So
here's some movie reviews.
This guy said,
punisher war zone and
he gives it three stars.
Punish your war zone.
What the fuck is that? Um,
evidently he says there's tons of
over the top violence and shooting.
It doesn't try to be realistic at all.
Like the last one,
the first punisher warzone tried to be
real. That's funny with that name. Uh,
the story was very basic
with no real twist. You know
what? I can appreciate that.
Okay. So it's like commando.
They fucked with them.
He got in his Bronco and he kicks
ass and then he wins. I like it.
I'm going to, I'm, you know
what, I'm not going to go see it,
but I will watch it on. Um, that'll
be the new part of the movie reviews.
I'll let you know if I'm going to
see it. I'm going to see that. Okay.
You guys still filled?
Now does this make any holidays?
I'm going to go see punish your
warts and, all right, I'm gonna,
I'm gonna sit on my fucking huge
couch and I'm going to watch it. Um,
the next review he did, the day the earth
stood still, he gave it three stars.
Guys, very, uh, he's very
liberal with the stars here.
Some people who are in the theater with
me were pissed at it when it ended,
but it's a remake and I
knew it was going to happen.
It isn't really supposed to be an over
the top independent stay blockbuster.
It's more story oriented.
And there was some surprise stars that
I didn't know were in it like so and so
and so and so. Well thanks for
ruining it for me. And I give a fuck.
I'm not really into those cameos. I hate
when people get excited about cameos.
[inaudible] time cruise kid had,
I had no idea he was in it. Yeah.
What'd be more surprising if like
one of your relatives walked in?
It's not like Tom Cruise isn't an actor.
You know,
it's not like he hasn't been
doing movies for 25 years.
I can't believe that actor all of a sudden
showed up in a movie and was acting.
I was really blown away. Um,
oh, I'm going to pissy mood.
Um, let's see. Oh, this is the
two movies I saw this weekend.
I saw the wrestler with Mickey Rourke,
which was fucking awesome.
And, uh, any, if you're a
fan of wrestling, if you're
a fan of Mickey Rourke,
you got to go see it. He's
fucking great. And, and, uh,
they really capture the
more ronic wrestling fan,
which I was perfectly.
And then I also saw that movie,
I'm milk starring Sean
Penn as Harvey Milk.
And I got to admit,
I was shying away from that movie.
I wanted to go see it because
I love Sean Penn, but every,
a male friend of mine was
saying, I was like, yeah,
I want to go see that movie milk. Uh,
did you see it? And they'd be like, yeah,
I saw it, but I just to warn
you, a lot of male kissing,
which is not a,
uh,
that's not a selling point with
a lot of guys, myself included.
And I was sitting there going, but I've
got to go see it. It's Sean Penn and um,
I don't know, there wasn't
a lot of kissing, but it,
after a while you sort of get used to it,
which I don't know if that's a good thing.
I'm really on the fence about that.
I don't know what the fuck. You
know what I mean? It's weird.
If I was on like a youporn or to bait,
and I was watching two guys kissing,
people will be looking at me like, dude,
what the fuck is wrong with you? You know,
what's your deal? You got
something to tell me. I can't
just sit there and be, oh,
it's just a porno. You
know, this is a, you know,
this is the, then he go see a movie
and then all of a sudden it's okay,
this is art. This is art. I don't
know. It wasn't that big a deal.
It wasn't an Sean Penn was fucking
unreal. And, uh, it was an amazing,
amazing movie with a lot of male kissing.
You know,
I gotta admit this the first time I've
seen an amazing movie that had a lot of
male kissing. I think they
started a whole new genre. Um,
so I don't know. You know
what I'm, because I have OCD,
I plan on seeing like fucking
nine more movies this week.
There's some mob movie I wanted to go see.
What the fuck was the name of that.
I'm going raise here.
This is Mrs Typical me.
Like I haven't seen a movie
in about eight months.
And then I go and I see one movie. Then
I'm like, I'm going to go see everything.
It's like, I don't understand why I
can't. This is why I don't do drugs.
I'm going to go see a Gamora, g. O,
m, O, r, r, a. H.
Evidently it's a mob movie
cause I gotta wash off that,
that male kissing to prove to myself in
a cinematic way that I'm still a man.
Um,
I'm going to go see this movie.
Evidently it's a mob movie that kind of
takes away all the Glam of being in the
mob. You know what I mean? I
mean, when you watch good fellows,
you don't really think like, wow,
thank God I never joined the Mafia.
You know, you, you, you
know you want the cars.
I don't know. You want the fucking, I
dunno. I can't say the women let me,
I'm pretty fucking nasty and good fellas.
You know what it was that girl with a
cold sore just ruins it for every woman in
that.
Then I just think they all have herpes
and then it just fucking ends it for me.
Can I just miss this up here?
Sorry guys.
This is going to be another slow podcast.
Fuck yourselves. I'm on vacation.
All right, let's get to the
podcast question. Sally. Um,
if you new to my podcast,
people send me podcast questions every
single week and I try and answer them to
the best of my ability. Um,
so here we go. Podcasts,
podcasts came even talk question
number one. Uh, Bill, uh,
I have a question for you as
a well-informed hockey fan.
What are your thoughts on the Chicago
Blackhawks chances this season? Um,
also what the fuck? Why the fuck
did the Bruins get rid of Thornton?
Uh, what do they get rid of? Thorton?
Cause they didn't feel like they could
lead them deep into the playoffs.
He played on a Bruins teams that people
felt they didn't have any heart and
cause he was the big paid guy. They
blamed him, which was a, wasn't fair.
All I know is we didn't get shit from,
we didn't get shit for the guy.
How do I think the black are going
to do this year? Uh, transition year.
They're not going to do shit.
Speaking of that,
let's talk about the New York Yankees
and them throwing their fucking wallet's
around. Huh? It's Monday and I've
heard that. I haven't watched ESPN yet,
but I heard they had this
close to signing Manny Ramirez.
So they signed cc Sabathia
that white dudes from Toronto,
the pitcher and uh,
I dunno,
I fucking love as a red sox fan.
I'm loving every second of it.
That's exactly right. Go ahead and
do the exact same fucking thing.
It's like watching an alcoholic,
just making the same fucking mistakes
over and over and over again thinking that
you're going to get a different result.
You've had a rod cheater in GMB
just in your fucking in field
for the last five years or whatever.
Or at least Jeter in GMB,
that Combo you had to send me, you
haven't won shit. You haven't won shit.
And Randy Johnson with those three
guys behind them. Plus, I mean,
look at the look at the list to start.
When the Yankees were the shit,
they got it from their farm team.
I don't know.
And then they would pick up these fucking
nerds along the way. Paul O'Neill,
who knew Lee was great. Scott Parotias
Knoblauch, you know, they just,
I don't know.
I don't know what they're doing.
They always go out and they get the
fucking big swinging Dick and then you,
you got, you got too much
swinging dick in your clubhouse.
There's, you're not
going to win. You can't.
If it was just that fucking easy,
the Yankees would win it every year.
Wouldn't they look a little bit
over? Not The fucking, the red sox.
Try doing that one year, I remember
that year we got a Eric Gun. Yay.
That guy almost fucked up our whole
season last year we got that big bloated
steroid jackass. Remember
that? And we'd already added a,
what's his face there in right field?
I swear to God the second the season as,
I can't even remember anybody's
name. I was going to say, Trot Nixon.
Know the new guy a fucking junior. Felix,
what the fuck is his name out there?
The guy everybody says is a cunt and
he doesn't do well during the season.
And then he shows, he shows
up in October. That guy,
I thought this the red sox
last year were very, uh, 2007.
We're teetering on that
Yankee esque sort of thing,
but they still had like four or five guys
from their, uh, from their farm team.
I don't understand what the Yankees are
doing, but I hope they keep doing it.
I hope they do it.
I hope they have a fucking $500 million
team and they get bounced out in the
first round.
That's going to be fucking a list of my
favorite part of the year in baseball is
when they pan down that Yankee dugout
and you just see one fucking zillionaire
to one hall of Famer after another.
Just fucking sitting there with that
look on their face and like, God,
Jesus Christ looks like, well on
all the early again this year.
I don't fucking know. You know, I
don't know. But I will say this,
Manny is what the money and uh,
he's definitely worth the fucking money.
Cc Sabathia only because he's 26,
but I gotta tell you, man, that
guy is built like Bartolo Cologne.
All right?
And you can't walk around with that
sack of potatoes hanging right over your
dick for too long before you
started having lower back pain.
You can't pitch anymore.
It's like broads with big tits.
They can ride it out to like 35, 37. And
after a while they're like, listen man, I,
I can't go today. I just can't do it.
You know, I'm fucking, my arm is shot
and see under their career and
they get their titties reduced.
So cc Sabathia needs to
stop going to the fucking,
what the fuck would he go
when to cc?
Sabathia seeing all of garden guy.
He's got the money though.
I don't know what he's doing.
He looks like he just has like one
of those MTV cribs refrigerators.
You know what I mean? When
they got like, you know,
they got like a case of fucking cocacola
and every bag of fucking junk food.
You know what?
I'm convinced fat people eat at night.
That's where they get fed because if you
hang out with a fat person, you know,
you hang out with them all day long.
They just sorta eating when you eat. Eh,
maybe they'll get an extra fucking
cheeseburger at Mcdonald's,
but they don't go anything crazy.
I think it's at night, at night,
that's when they get up and they just
start going through the cupboards and they
just,
they just start throwing the fuck down.
I think that's what cc Sabathia is going
to be doing on the road with any luck.
Um, I dunno. What the fuck are
you gotta do? Um, what else?
I'm going to keep talking to a sports.
I think I'm going to piss off everybody.
At least half in New York.
You've got so many fucking teams met fans.
Probably enjoyed that. What about those
jets? Huh? Can you fucking believe it?
They choked against the Goddamn Seahawks
and they're the patriots right in the
thick of it. And I know what you're
going to say. You can say Bill,
you fucking bandwagon.
Well,
that's bullshit because I got a
bet with the shred and Reagan show,
which I'm going to fuck. Fuck, I
didn't call him. It's too late.
The shred and Reagan show out in Buffalo,
New York.
I bet them the fucking week
when Tom Brady went down,
Reagan was talking all this shit,
and I hope he's listening to this.
He was talking all this shit.
Bill Belicheck is a punk.
He's never one without a superstar
quarterback, Yada, Yada, Yada.
All this fucking crap. And I said,
let me tell you something, Reagan,
let me tell you something.
And Reagan,
not only other patriots
can have a winning season.
They are going to fucking
win the division. I called
that after Brady went down,
called the, I bet him 50 bucks. If I
lose, I own 50 bucks. But if I win,
Reagan has to read an,
uh,
an on air apology to build
Bella check that I get to write.
It's going to be great.
Now he negotiated it down to only
six sentences. It can only be,
the apology can only
be six sentences long,
but he's not familiar with
my ability with conjunctions.
All right,
that fucking thing is going to be a page
and a half of what a brilliant coach.
Bill Belichick is there. Those guys on
ESPN was saying that Shit, you know,
he's never worn with Dota superstar
quarterback and neither did Vince Lombardi
needed a chuck Noll. Neither the
Tom Landry, neither did Bill Walsh.
Those guys all suck.
Joe Gibbs,
Joe Gibbs never really had
a superstar quarterback.
Doug Williams was a superstar who
just played for the Buccaneers.
You know what I mean? So maybe he did,
but he didn't want mark ripping and
Joe financial ties. One was on the
fence. Who's like Apollo Neal level guy.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking
about. All I know is next week,
although this is what,
this is what I love about this situation.
Next week in New York can actually help
Boston have a great fucking new years.
If they can beat the shit out of the
dolphins, if they can show up, huh?
Your punk ass team will show up and when
a Goddamn game going out to Seattle and
lose and you guys ought to be ashamed
of yourselves, why am I picking on jets?
Fans actually feel bad for you guys if you
didn't have man genie, man. Genio like,
all right.
He drove the getaway car all those
fucking years and then he read it out.
Bill Belicheck. Oh look, he's robbing
a bank. Dude. You're driving the car.
Shut the fuck up.
Fucking baby.
All right.
Am I even doing questions at this point?
I'm just talking shit about sports.
How about those Bruins?
How about those Celtics? Huh? I
didn't need to go home for Christmas.
The fucking Boston teams
of bringing it home for me.
It got the NHL package.
I've only watched the first period
of the Saint Louis Blues game.
Don't ruin it for me. Don't be a spoiler.
All right, question number two. Bill.
What do you think of MTV? Swisher sweet.
Jesus Christ. I can read out loud.
I'm fucking Moron, Bill. Let's go slow.
What do you think of MTVs sweet 16 show
and part two. What did you do
for your sweet 16? All right,
what do I think of the sweet 16
show? Uh, it makes me angry. Um,
I try to keep my mind that there
are only 16, but I just really,
I don't like dumb cunts,
you know,
I don't like it when I'm walking down
the street and I'm certainly not going to
watch your show about it. So,
uh, that's how I feel about that.
And what did I do for my sweet 16?
I went down to the DMV and
I got my learner's permit.
That's what I did was I was a big deal
for me learning how to drive and, uh,
what did I do? I have no
idea. I have no fucking idea.
I don't remember that Shit
fucking 24 years ago. Uh,
number three. I like how I took
that question and literally like,
what did you do for your sweet 16, you
know, I guess I was supposed to be like,
well, I put ribbons in my hair. I
literally took it like straight up,
like I have no idea what I did.
That was 24 years ago.
Well thanks for sucking all the
comedy out of that question, Bill.
Sorry about that. Whoever wrote
that, he sent me up. Beautiful.
You loved it over the net and
I took a big swing and a miss.
Kind of like a rod and October. Oh,
he's killing the Yankees. All right.
Nah,
there's somebody right now who already
has a fucking Manny Ramirez poster
hanging over his bed.
Fucking Ballston to Townsel fucking lame.
Everything fucking closes you fucking tool
in the fucking morning. What the fuck?
Yeah. We also go out at seven 30
at night and we start drinking.
You fucking jackass is still putting
on Cologne at 1130 at night. All right,
so fuck you and your city
that opened is open all night.
What a crock of shit that was.
You know what?
I'm first moved in New York another time
I took it literally like when they said
New York, the city that never
sleeps, it's open all night long.
I thought that meant everything.
Like banks, hardware stores.
You know what I mean?
Like I go, I could buy a lamp at like,
you know, three 30 in the morning.
But no, it does. It does shut down
and people do go to sleep and,
but their bars do stay up until four
in the morning. Other than that,
I fucked that. It's the greatest
Goddamn city. It's our Paris.
I'm not even gonna lie to you.
It's fucking awesome. I love it.
But I really don't like their sports
teams. Um, okay. If you didn't notice,
all right,
why don't you get back to the questions
and stop making it so fucking personal
with one city.
There's other cities listening and other
countries hello to all the people in
England that I've been getting
questions from lately. Um,
I'm going to be over that next year. You
mother fuckers. Um, so, uh, you know,
I don't know. Whatever it is you do
to get prepared for comedy shows.
What do you do in England?
Do you guys really,
pork chops for breakfast actually
watched that show. You are what you eat.
You know, which made me feel a lot better
about how out of shape this country is.
When I saw all those people over there
like you know w what do you start?
You did well I start my day,
I have like,
I have a couple of fry ups and
for you Americans listening,
a fry up is rather than just making
it an egg over easy, you know,
cooking it and butter fried frying an egg,
they actually,
from what I gather from the
footage, because it's not
like they have the recipe,
they pour like cooking oil
into a pot and they boil it.
It's almost like you're
poaching an egg in Greece.
So they have like four of those to start
the day. And then they have laid out,
have like these little fucking,
I don't know,
these little pork sandwiches and
they're really big on Indian food.
Why do you guys have so
many Indians over there?
Literally people from India is at the
whole Winston Churchill thing, you know,
that's another book I started
reading and I never got through.
I really wanted to get through that
book so I can sound intelligent at some
point. It was a whole book about
the relationship between, oh,
was it Winston Churchill and Gandhi
gets fucking whacked. Just,
you know, it's unbelievable.
All these people out there who think
that they're being dangerous on stage and
type of, you know, if nobody's
made an attempt on your life,
you're not saying anything.
That's when you know that you're
on stage saying something,
I think is when somebody tries to fucking
shoot you in the back of the head at
that point. Right. Then
you're saying something,
but you know enough with
all these dangerous artists.
I really hate that shit.
When people take, they had head
shots and they have like a, you know,
they have like a piece of tape
over their mouth, like, like the,
the government put it, you know,
that piece of duct taping lunch.
Stupid fucking like, Ooh, he's
dangerous. He's doing some spoken word.
He figured out a word that rhymes with
Illuminati. Everybody run for cover.
He's going to sing a song about the
work and man, you're not dangerous.
Okay, okay. Is he dangerous?
They try to kill you and they do.
All right. Okay. You know, did
fucking Martin Luther King,
I have a poster of himself with the
fucking, you know, and you know,
piece of tape over his mouth and shrugging
his shoulder like, ugh. Well eat.
What did they do? He booked
the good day. All right. Um,
let's get back to the questions.
Question number three though.
Have you ever been dealing with the
case of the runs all day and had to go
onstage? Tough it out, cold
sweats, bubbling stomach,
stomach and all, you know,
I love this question as he could have
asked me anything and I would have
answered it. And he just basically
said [inaudible] go on stage and like,
yeah, to take a shit really bad, you
know, like, well what was that like?
Did that ever happen to me? Uh, yeah,
it's happened to me a number of times and
I've been doing it for almost 17 years.
Um, I've had an untimely fucking
salad that went right through me.
Garlic is another thing
I don't do well with.
And the amazing thing is the second
you go on stage, for the most part,
it stops, uh, I don't know,
some sort of survival adrenaline thing
kicks in that, uh, just says, oh,
wait a second. We're not shitting.
No, we're not. No, we're not. Okay.
So you just need to
shut down that thought.
You need to sit there and wait until I'm
done with this stuff that I've had the
hiccups right before I went
on stage going, oh my God,
I have hiccups. What am I,
what am I going to do in the second
I get out there? They go away.
I don't know why, but they do. So
yeah, I've, I've had to do that.
I've heard stories of comedians
literally being onstage,
stopping the show and just saying, I
have to, uh, I have to lead now. In fact,
I want to say Dana Gould told a story
like that the other day on the Adam
Carolla show. Um, I dunno.
I Dunno. I can't remember. Anyways, let's
get back to the question. Say Shall, okay,
here we go. Um, let's see. Let's see.
Let's see. Question number four. Bill,
if you could be with
the girl of your dreams,
any girl marry her,
have great sex every night,
everything was great and you were happy,
but you had to sleep with one guy.
Any guy in the whole rural world,
who would the guy be?
And who would the girl be?
Great fucking question.
Let's get with the guy. That's
the easy one. That would be, um,
one of those unbelievably
over the top gay guys.
You know,
those guys who were just like this.
So they're the ones who actually,
they get gay bashed and the reason they
get gay bash, just because there's,
so putting out a female vibe,
it confuses the mail.
That's why they, you know,
and if you're not, you know, if you're
a psycho, you get so pissed. Like,
why am, why am, why am I
feeling like this? This is a
female. When it's a guy, you,
you just start punching it because you
don't know how to, I don't know. Well,
I don't know the motivation behind fucking
gay bash and all I could say, yeah,
I would find the most, uh, over the top,
but not like that dude on willing
grace cause he's still a dude.
He's just sort of skipping around
I guess the most of feminine.
I'm trying to think maybe like one
of those, uh, if it's like Filipino,
some little Asian hairless dude,
I go that way. You know what
I mean? Yeah. I go that way.
Um, and if it had to be any girl in the
world, who would it be? Ah, Jesus Christ.
Um, I dunno. Everybody
goes with somebody famous,
what would it be? You know what
I want, you know what I do?
I would go back to my
adolescence when I was innocent.
And you know,
when you back then,
when you actually looked at a girl and
you had like a number that way, that uh,
what the for that Biloxi blues with a
guide just described that that little mini
heart attack,
you know,
when you lean back in a chair at
a couple of girls back in the day,
when I looked at him,
I felt that like that lightening bolt,
which only happens when you're
young, when you get older, you just,
you just spent through it too many
times. And again, I look at those shoes,
she probably likes to get
tied up. How old is she? 28.
She's probably on her second fucking
major relationship, you know,
let's find out if her
parents are still together.
That's always a good fucking
measuring stick. You know,
you start thinking like that and he just
lose it. So I would go back then and uh,
yeah, I would do, and I'm not
gonna say the girl's name,
probably a girl back then.
Well,
one of the two or three girls back there
that fucking made me out of a heart
attack. I would hook up
with them. You know what,
that was actually a very sweet answer.
I Bet I have a lot of females going. Ah,
I see. Really sweet. He does have a census
site and there's a bunch of guys. What?
I'm fucking queer. Um, all right,
question number five,
Bill. I was searching,
I was searching through youtube and
I found this interesting video file.
It was Jesse Ventura talking about how
most of September 11th was caused by our
government. And I'll fill
you non wrestling fans are
political people out there.
Jesse Ventura used to be a professional
wrestler, went by Jesse the body Ventura.
And one of my favorite things that
they used to call Tito Tito Santana.
Santana used to call him Chico Santana.
And uh,
he was part of the tag team champion. Uh,
what was it? Larry's Abisko Bisco Tony.
Gloria. Who the fuck was Tito Santana?
Was He with Ivan Pushkey? Tito Santana?
Let me, I don't care about no
cheat. Go Santana. He was awesome.
And then he also said that Song Jessie's
girl was about him. Um, but anyways,
he was also a fucking, was
he a senator in Minnesota?
So anyways, that's the guy's background
with my fucking digression there.
Say a former wrestler, former senator I
believe, or a representative of Minnesota.
And anyways,
he was talking about how most of September
11th was caused by our government and
how we blew up the two World
Trade Center towers towers.
He said from his experiences in the navy
seals that buildings don't fall at the
rate of gravity. Your
thoughts, thanks again. Um,
my first gut feeling is they don't teach
you how to implode a skyscraper when
you joined the Navy seals.
And um,
buildings don't fall
at the rate of gravity.
I don't feel that they teach
you that in the navy seals.
I think they teach you
how to swim underwater,
how to cut somebody with a knife from ear
to ear and not have any guilt over it.
How to move stealthily, how to kill
people. I don't think at any point,
I'm trying to think of anything that
the navy seals were accused of any
skyscraper implosions
that they were accused of,
but our government denied any sort of
knowledge of granted it would be top
secret.
Um,
I'm guessing he went on
youtube like me and a watch,
the same conspiracy
theories that I watched, uh,
those same videos and now he's trying to
act like he came up with it himself to
make himself sound a little
more intelligent by throwing
in the navy seals thing.
You know, from my experience
in the Navy Seals, uh,
buildings don't fall at the
rate of gravity. Really.
Did they teach you that
when you're putting on your
flippers, you jackass when,
when the fuck did they teach you that?
You know what I mean?
I'm sure they tell you how to climb up
the side of a building, but, you know,
I don't really think it's
in, you know, we have,
we have six teams to take down buildings.
We don't have fucking eight guys
in frog suits do that. You know,
I think he's just throwing it out there
that's like, well, you know, a bill,
what do you think about September
11th? Well, my experience as a,
a headlining con comedian around the
country leads me to believe that a
building's don't fall at the rate
of gravity. So, uh, yeah. Uh,
excuse me. I have a third show tonight,
you know, if he was an architect,
I would believe that.
Um,
I guess you're asking me what
am I thoughts do I think,
I dunno what happened on September 11th.
I know there's a lot of,
there's a lot of questions and I don't
feel like we're being told the whole
story. And I'm not saying our government
did it, but I don't know what happened,
but I know it's not what they told me.
I think they told you some
of what happened and then
other stuff they felt like
they couldn't tell you.
And then other shit they use to manipulate
shit so they could do some other shit,
which is why we're all in a big
bag of shit right now. All right,
question number six. Bill parents
named their kid. Uh Oh yeah.
I saw this story to parents named
their kid, one of their kids,
Adolf Hitler and another one area nation.
I think it's great.
Now we can keep an eye on the
little fuckers. Oh, wait a minute.
That's my response. I was like, wow,
this kid agrees with me. Um, yeah,
I do think it's great. I think
it's, it's for that exact reason.
You know what I mean?
The next Adolf Hitler is not going to be
named Adolf Hitler or airing a nation.
His name is going to be like Mike
or Jason. You know what I mean?
It's, you know, I don't know. I don't
know how to fuck you explain it.
It's like any, anytime somebody
comes along and look, oh dude,
he sees the next Jimmy Hendrix. You
know, it's like there's never another,
Jimi Hendrix is never going to be another
eight or they're not gonna be another
fucking guy with the same name. You
named a kid Adolf Hitler, Joseph Stalin.
They're not going to walk. They're
not going to do anything. You just,
you gave them a tattoo.
You know Adolf Hitler came to power.
He actually ran for office when new,
nobody knew the name Adolph Hitler.
And he got in there and once he
got in there with these guys,
that's when he started doing shit.
So if this little fucker ever runs
for all for, for office, he can't,
you know,
it's great.
That just hung a sign around
them. Hey, attention. My, uh,
my parents were fucking maniacs
and I'm filled with hate. You know,
he can't run for office. Who you, who
you voted for? You vote for Obama.
You voted for a fucking, uh, John McCain.
Are you voting for I Adolf Hitler
and his running mate. Arian nation.
I think all racist should name their
kids. Stuff like that, you know,
just, you know, name them,
fucked up, names like that,
and then they can all giggle about it.
Hey, there's little Adolf and then we'll,
you know, it's like the, you know,
I don't know how many times could
I make the same fucking point.
[inaudible] I really don't give a shit.
Um, I don't think it's offensive either.
I think those people can name their kids,
whatever the fuck they want to
name them. And, uh, like I said,
some major red flag.
Dad,
can I go to my friend's house? Yes. Uh,
well what will we go? Oh, you want him
to Steve's house? No, Adolph eight.
His kids' names. Adolph. Yeah.
What's his last name? Hitler
saw y'all. Can I go? No, no,
you can't. Why not? Well,
I'll explain it to you.
Like why don't we sit down and watch the
history channel together? I know. Water.
What's boring? Shut the fuck up. You
Little Brat. Question number seven. Um,
since you've been traveling across
the country for the past decade or so,
what's the best urban
legend you ever heard of?
Okay. Urban legends. Uh, I've
heard so many good ones. Um,
I,
well I grew up in the 80s,
so there was a lot of fear
about aids during that time.
And um, I remember there was
an urban legend about a guy.
He's in a bar,
he makes this chick,
she's totally smoke and looks
like a fucking supermodel.
They go back to her place,
you know, whenever her hotel,
she gives him the best blow job ever
and the bang and I would fly out of the
greatest fucking night ever.
He wakes up the next morning she's gone
and he walks into the bathroom and then
on the mirror is written in lipstick.
Congratulations.
Now we both have aides because
evidently he didn't use a condom.
And I remember being in a room when a
warehouse believing every word going,
really do what we do. Where, where
did that happen? I don't know, Dude.
I think it was in Rhode Island.
I was a moron.
I liked that one. And I liked a, there
was another one out there about a guy,
he meets a girl in a bar
and uh, she says, hey,
and she's totally smoking. And
she says, Hey, this is the deal.
You can come back to Mike's Place.
You can do whatever you want to me.
But in the end I get to do whatever I want
to you guys like, yeah, Shit, fucking,
let's go. So, you know,
he does everything you could possibly do
with the woman you know, has an orgasm,
everything's great. And she
goes, okay, now it's my turn.
And she ties him down to
the bed. So he's like, okay,
she's under this freaky Dominic's or
shit, whatever. She walks out of the room,
you know,
closes the door and all of a sudden the
door fucking kicks open and there's a
black dude dressed like Batman and he
comes in and he fucks the guy in the ass.
And I actually believed it. Like that
totally made sense to me. I was like,
once again,
1819.
Where did that happen? I don't
know. I think it was in Chelsea.
Um, yeah, probably that one. And then,
then anyone, any of the firecracker,
urban legends,
you know,
somebody put an mad and somebody's
back pocket and blew half his ass off.
I always liked that one. Um,
yeah, I would say that. All right.
And it's the second part
of the question also.
Do you believe in Spooky
Supernatural Shit? No. Yes or no?
I believe in outer body experiences.
I believe in some sort of a,
I don't know.
I don't even know after life,
but so just some shit that we don't,
we don't understand that we can't tap
into. I definitely believe in that,
but I don't believe in ghosts
like there that you know,
that they're going to haunt me. I
just don't get what it goes. Can Do.
You know, it's invisible.
I can't see it. Okay.
So what does it rattles a land
and it goes boom. All right.
Now that I get used to that, um, you know,
the worst he can just be as a pain in
the ass, just not shit off my dresser
and then just be like, really? Then
I can just fuck with him mentally.
Just torture stick really
well, maybe that's why. Maybe
that's why you're a ghost.
You ever think about that?
Maybe you're just a content life in
your punishment is you don't get to go
anywhere and now you're
trapped in my awful apartment,
you know, kind of a fucking
loser. Ghosts are you,
why aren't you out there looking up
women's skirts and we get gay ghost.
Once you go fucking float
over to a west, uh, west,
it's plenty of dudes over there.
You know, we'll get their balls.
I ain't know what I'm talking
about here. All right. Um, anyways,
he said my girlfriend is obsessed with
that show goes hunter hunter hunters.
And I find it ridiculous. Uh, yeah,
I find that shows that
shows that's fucking stupid.
It's all all in the editing and they
act like they're going to find something
and they don't and they never quite
get like a good angle on the ghost.
You know? It's like if you
had a good angle on the ghost,
you have kept the footage and you
would've just could have sold it to any
network out there for millions of dollars.
We finally have proof that goes exist,
but they never do until we shaky
handheld Blair witch shit. All right,
question number eight. Um,
bill doing sets every week,
do you ever get bored of your own
stories? Jesus Christ? Yes, absolutely.
Which is why, and thank God I do. If I
didn't, I would never write any new jokes.
Absolutely. Absolutely. And what ends up
happening is if it's a seven minute joke,
it becomes a five minute joke.
It becomes a two minute joke and then
it just becomes a joke that disappears.
It's kind of like,
you know,
you ever like break your arm or
something and someone's like, dude,
what happened to your arm?
And you tell the first person you tell
in total detail what happened to your arm
and it takes like fucking 10 minutes.
The next guy who tell you
start telling it again.
You can fuck he going
over the same shit again,
becomes eight minutes and then the very
end, it's just what happened? Your mom,
dude, I fucking fell down and go fuck
yourself. What do you think happened?
It bent in a way. It wasn't supposed
to bend in a broke. All right,
what happened to your face? All
right, question number nine.
How far into this podcast,
how are we, how many?
I'm trying to shorten these things
because they're getting ridiculously long.
41 minutes. Jesus Christ. I should
sell cds at the end of this. All right,
question number nine, and I'm going
to wrap this up real quick. Um, Bill,
are there any movies that you,
that you know are God awful,
but for whatever reason you love them
anyways? Oh, I like this. This is,
this is a good story here.
Listen to this shit he says for me is
John Claude van Damme bloodsport and
kickboxer reasoning being is I was about
nine or 10 when those movies came out
and they were the first movies.
My Dad let me stay up and watch with
them even though my mom disapproved and I
saw kickboxer for the first time in a
while the other day and it really might be
one of the worst movies of all time,
especially the part where van Damme
gets punched square in the face about 15
times and rapid succession at the end
of the round and at the end of the round
the bad guy tells van dam
that he fucked his girlfriend.
At which point van Damme spends the
rest of a in between rounds demanding to
know the truth about his new girlfriend.
He says,
if I were in the middle of a fight with
the grand champion of underground death
matches, would you actually
give a shit at that point?
Who some girl you met two
weeks ago? Fuck yeah, exactly.
And I'll never forget
the part with a bad vet.
Bad Guy's boss finally gets what's coming
to him because my dad would always be
going take that you
Cambodian son of a bitch.
I don't even think the guy was supposed
to be Cambodian, but I, but if I see them,
movie's going to be on, on
Cinemax 20 years from now.
Still sit down and watch it.
Yeah, I got movies like that. Um,
I think I already talked about this one
airport in 1975 if he ever get a chance
to watch that movie,
that's the movie that basically the
movie airplane was making fun of.
I believe.
And believe it or not,
air as funny as the movie airplane
is airport 1975 is even funnier.
Just to give you a quick recap of,
of what the store at what it is.
It's a commercial airliner. You
know, some guys in a private plane,
he has a heart attack and has a
head on collision with like a DC 10,
which sucks one of the pilots out of the
front and blinds Efram Zimbalist Jr at
which point a stewardess who
I swear to God has a lazy eye,
has to fly the fucking plane and it stars
an unknown Erik Estrada who plays the
character of I believe heck
door and has one line in it.
It's that fucking good. All right,
what am I going to end with here?
Um, let's end with a wishing all you
guys are merry Christmas. So it be guys,
you know, you're Jewish, had
happy Hanukkah. Um, if you're,
uh,
is it just black,
the only black people or is that
African Kwanza Happy Kwanza Duration?
I don't know what you do
there. A old Jewish people, uh,
have y'all have excellent Chinese food
on Christmas Day? I learned that little,
uh, that little tradition the other day.
Oh, here's a question I have for any, any,
you technically savvy guys out here
cause I really want to up the quality of
these podcasts. If people keep talking
about this tapping, wait a minute,
is it this noise?
Is that the noise?
If that's the noise. Yeah, that's
me scrolling down on my computer.
I think we solved it.
Um,
son of a bitch anyways,
so I want to up the quality.
So let me know if that's the tapping
sound because some people were saying it
was my laugh saying I left like Popeye
and annoyed them. Or is it this,
is that really annoying you guys?
Um, anyways, this is my question.
I saw something, I was
listening to a, what's his face?
Little Stephens underground Christmas.
If you guys ever listened to his show
notes on Sunday nights, check out locally.
He's just said plays on this underground
music plays great music and I love the
way he talks.
A little Stevens underground Christmas,
we got the limo moves. I can't even do
what this fucking the coolest dude ever.
But anyways, he was talking about
this shit on there called the uh,
the Olympus ls 10.
And evidently it's this
fucking unbelievable recorder.
You can record 12 hours with a
shit on it. Bands can use it. Like,
that's how much quality is that you can
just set it in the middle of the room
and it picks up everything.
Like that cheesy guitar playing that
you heard at the beginning of this.
You could have really
told how awful it was.
If I get one of these devices
and any you tech geeks out there,
I want to know if this thing is worth it.
The ls 10 if I start recording my
podcasts on this, then uploading them.
It's really adding an whole extra step
to the process. But I would like to,
you know, I'm getting a ton of
listeners, I'm not gonna lie to you,
the podcast that kind of
starting to blow up. You know,
I think I'm in a triple
digits at this point.
I know I've been joking San only have 14
listeners, but I really think I got a,
I think I have about 106 at this point,
so I'm gonna,
I'm gonna try to, uh, you know,
try to up the quality here in 2009.
Um, and with that I got an idea.
How about for next week's podcast?
You guys send me in some
New Year's resolutions,
how are you going to
turn your lives around?
You know how you do this every
year you lie to yourself,
you're gonna make your life a
little bit better. You know,
send me those in. And with that I'm going
to end this podcast here. I'm going to,
well actually hype a couple of dates
I have coming up. Um, all right,
this is the big one. I'm at the
Improv in Tampa, Florida and I,
last time I was there, you know, I dunno,
I didn't do so well as
far as drawing people.
I know it's kind of off the
beaten path down there in Tampa.
Maybe the hang over a
year fucking devil rays,
which kicked the shit out of my red
sox while we took you to seven games.
So you guys are definitely the
better team. Maybe you guys,
you know the lightening aren't doing so
well that kind of an okay team come out
to one of my shows is what I'm
saying. January 8th, ninth the 10th,
the You saw my uh,
last hour special.
I wrote a brand new hours stuff and
I'm also going to be at the Improv in
Houston, Texas on uh, January
22nd through the 24th.
And then I'm making a hometown stop in
Boston at the Wilbur theater on February
the sixth. I really hope
you guys can come out. Um,
I'm going to be really
rested up over the holidays,
so I'm going to be extra funny.
I guaran fucking tee it and uh,
and that is it. I didn't quite get a
chance to get to some of this shit.
I got a couple of Nice reviews
on my podcast here.
This is all garbage time.
You don't even have to
listen to this ship it.
Here's a couple of Nice reviews I got.
And then I have another one,
another segment that I like to call back
down to earth where somebody trashes
May. So here we go. Here's
a couple of Nice one. Um,
thanks for making me laugh all day long.
I just finished listening to all of your
podcasts. How the fuck did you do that?
I'm trying to get my
wife to listen to them,
but she doesn't think it's
as funny as I think they are.
Anytime I have my headphones
on and I'm laughing, she says,
are you listening to your boyfriend
bill? Too Funny. Keep up the great work.
Don't you love when fucking women do shit
like that? Look at that. She's jealous.
She's jealous that you get, I, you know
what? You should play this part for her.
What's her name? Give me your
name next week. I'll, I'll have,
I'll give her a little talking to,
you know,
and I'll be nice even though she doesn't
think I'm not funny. You know this. Look,
if you want to hold on, you know I'm
gonna do it right now, sweetheart.
If you want to hold on to your boyfriend,
he can't suffocate him. All right?
If he likes walking around, listening to
another man and his headphones, you know,
show us a little gay. I
understand that. You know,
he's getting in touch with
his feminine side. All right?
But what you need to do is you
need to be an adult here. Okay?
You have to understand that.
No matter how stupid you think it is,
it's one of his hobbies and
you have to respect that. Okay?
Don't do what Jennifer Lopez did.
The Ben Affleck during their
year and a half relationship.
What are you going to do?
Dress him up like a little Ken doll.
Stick them in a Tuxedo.
Huh?
He can walk around smiling,
pretending he's happy and everybody sees
them misery behind his eyes, you know?
And then one day, you know, you
just, you just, yeah, I don't know.
You just see him crouched over in front
of his laptop looking at porn or just
something, something awful
and you're going to blame him.
You going to blame his childhood. You
know what? It's you lady. All right.
So why don't you back off during
the holidays. Okay. All right,
next one.
Hey Bill,
I think your podcast should come
with the public service disclaimer.
Since I fly a lot, I catch up on
your podcasts during flights through,
I get such a kick out of this if people
are actually downloading these things
and listening to them. This is
really cool. And so anyways,
on a plane and he says,
I sat next to this older lady during
a recent flight back from Portland.
It was your podcast about
chips and the 20 car pile ups.
I was frigging laughing so hard.
I couldn't breathe.
I thought I was going to be escorted
off the flight by air marshals.
This poor lady must've thought I
was a some psycho. All right. Yeah.
That's awesome. That makes me feel
good. Next one, one more good one,
and then I'm going to bring myself back
down to earth with somebody who trashed
me. All right, Bill. Then yesterday, uh,
it was the same one yesterday I was with
my older daughter and we were listening
in the car.
This was a podcast about being a boxer
and reacting to punches by shrugging your
shoulders and turning your head. I, yeah,
that's how I react to when somebody
tries to punch me in the face.
I don't try to slip the punch.
I just bring my shoulders up to ear
level and then I turned my head away
to,
I never want to fight anyways.
He said we were both
crying and gasping for air.
I could barely see the car in front of me.
Good God.
Warn people they should not be in public,
uh,
or operating heavy machinery
when listening. All right,
so that's the good review section.
Now here is the back down to earth
section of the podcast. Bill,
glad to see you've been working on,
you're reading out loud skills.
You sound like a special ed kid that
didn't bother getting out of the bus when
it arrived at school.
I wonder how many times you've been in
public places reading up out the podcast
questions into your phone and people
have walked by and thought, oh, how nice.
The mentally challenged man
over there is learning to read.
I guess he's really
coming along because he,
he's only sounding out every other word.
Know what's great about that.
Not only is that absolutely correct,
I actually had difficulty reading out
loud the thing that he said, insulting me,
saying I can't read out loud about
to shade to shade at Buddy. Um,
anyways, happy holidays, deputy buddy.
Merry Christmas. Happy Hanukkah.
Happy Kwanzaa. And if you don't celebrate
any of it, I hope you have a good break.
While the rest of us are spending money
on people that we resent on some level,
um, that is it. Um, let me know
your new years resolutions.
Please keep the podcast questions coming
and I hope in January I can have some
sort of update on my European tour
that I'm going to be doing, um,
next year.
So for my seven listeners in the U
K A I dunno if you guys celebrate.
Do you guys have Jesus over there? I
know you have Mcdonald's. All right.
God bless. Take it easy.
Talk to you next Monday.
So
maybe somewhere down the road,
maybe somewhere down the road when
somebody,
the
car I drive.
I'm just glad to be here.
Happy to theme that.
It doesn't matter if you
said
right.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].